hi everyone it's jerry here's another
interesting endgame study this one
composed by a.s celestiniev and
published in 1935.
it's white to move
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white
okay the solution here
is one that i find very aesthetic
one of the more aesthetic puzzles
i think you'll encounter in chess
there are four key moves to its solution
and each move highlights an interesting
feature
the first move
rook c8 is the tactic of deflection
king takes rook
followed up with now b7 placing black in
a fork
and after king b8
we don't take the rook he's going
nowhere
and instead we play d5
placing our opponent in
he has no legal moves except for king c7
none of the pawns can move the rook
can't move
king c7 is the only move and now he's
not there to defend the rook
this fourth move is now capped off
with pawn takes rook
and now we promote
in the rarest of ways
to a bishop this is the only move
that wins
capturing the rook and promoting to a
queen or rook
results in stalemate
and promoting to a knight
while this lands with check
after king b8 the knight will be won
back and this position will be a draw
the only solution here again
is to capture the rook and under promote
again in the rarest of ways to a bishop
and white will be winning this picking
up the a pawn and then hunting down both
black d-puns
and pushing through to produce a new
queen
what a cool puzzle this was
deflection
fork
placing our opponent in zukswang and
then finally
promoting to a bishop what a cool puzzle
feel free to share how you did with this
one
and i'll catch you in the next video
take care bye
you